bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
donner des astuces pour vous aider à
aller plus loin dans vos téléphones des
astuces et des secrets je donnerai
régulièrement d'ailleurs ça vous
intéresse je vous invite à vous abonner
comme ça vous serez toujours plus
d'astuces des tutos des infos sur les
terrains permet même chose aujourd'hui
nous donner des astuces pour votre
smartphone ios mais également pour
android on va regarder ça
[Musique]
il existe peu d'astuce pour ios et pour
android pour aller plus loin dans
l'utilisation vos smartphones on va
regarder ça aujourd'hui je vous donnais
plusieurs astuces certaines sont connues
doc le sont beaucoup moins
mais en tout cas elles sont toutes hyper
intéressante si votre batterie commence
à se décharger et qu'il faut que vous la
recharger rapidement mais que vous avez
relativement très peu de temps devant
vous et vous devez repartir sous dix
minutes
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est de
passer en mode avion lorsque vous le
recharger tout simplement parce que
lorsque vous laissez votre téléphone
dans le char d'une façon habituelle
vous allez consommer plus de batterie
parce que vous allez dans des
applications qui vont travailler en
arrière-plan
votre smartphone va être connecté au
réseau cellulaire il va y avoir
énormément d'applications qui vont
utiliser le réseau 3g 4g ou alors votre
wifi le mieux si vous voulez pour
optimiser votre chargement c'est de ne
pas consommer du tout et de se recharger
d'où le fait de passer en mode avion
vous allez voir gré les recharger votre
smartphone beaucoup plus vite et comme
ça faisait pouvoir repartir avec
beaucoup plus de batterie en réserve
effectivement ça peut paraître très
logique mais on n'y pense pas forcément
autre astuce pour iphone en règle
générale lorsqu'on écrit un message et
puis qu'on n'est pas trop sûr de ce
qu'on a envie d'écrire combat retaper le
message plusieurs fois au lieu de vous
embêter à revenir en arrière à chaque
fois ce que vous faites vous connais
votre iphone et vous le secouer ça va
vous proposer d'annuler votre saisie et
ses stores encore de plus simple comme
ça vous pourrez recommencer retaper sans
vous embêter à chaque fois à faire
effacer effacé effacer une autre astuce
maintenant qui marche aussi bien sur ios
et sur android
lorsque vous avez des jeux lorsque vous
amuser avec des applications la plupart
on prend des versions gratuites on va
pas s'amuser à prendre des versions
payantes à chaque fois par contre
l'inconvénient des versions gratuites et
ben c'est que vous avez forcément des
publicités qui sont relativement
intrusive qui risque d'arriver à un
moment où vous êtes en train de jouer ça
peut vous en mettez donc lorsque vous
voulez jouer tranquillement pendant un
quart d'heure une des meilleures que
voulait pas du tout être embêté vous
passez en mode avion comme ça votre
application by pourra tout simplement
pas se connecter au réseau cellulaire
elle vous changera pas et publicité et
vous serez peinard maintenant une astuce
spécialement pour ios une astuce qui
peut d'ailleurs vous sauver la vie je
vous conseille dans votre application de
santé de rentrer votre fiche médicale
nom prénom âge
si vous êtes vacciné si vous avez des
allergies
vous avez des traitements médicamenteux
de rentrer les personnes à contacter en
cas d'urgence toutefois vous aviez un
problème un accident où on ne sait pas
quoi d'autre vous rentrez 1 vous rentrez
deux numéros on sait pas ça peut vous
sauver la vie et ça c'est hyper
intéressant parce que c'est facile sur
android lorsque vous êtes en
communication téléphonique pour
raccrocher
vous avez forcément votre téléphone là
il vous devait le mettre face à vous et
appuyer sur le bouton pour raccrocher
c'est bien mais ce n'est pas forcément
ce qui est plus rapide
il ya un petit mode secret qui est caché
à l'intérieur de paramètres qui vous
permettra directement de raccrocher en
appuyant sur le bouton on off ce qui
fait que lorsque vous avez votre
appareil lac voulais raccrocher vous
n'avez plus qu'à appuyer avec votre
pouce directement là et ça va raccrocher
sans forcément de vous embêter
maintenant une astuce qui est quand même
relativement connus sur ios et sur
android ailleurs sur tous les
smartphones en règle générale lorsque
vous voulez appeler quelqu'un vous vous
l'appelez un anonyme vous voulez pas
être reconnus sans forcément aller dans
les réglages de votre téléphone à chaque
fois et de masquer votre numéro de
téléphone
ce que vous faites vous tapez dies 31
diez puis le numéro de la personne à
juin et de cette manière vous ferez un
appel masqué alors ça ne vaut que pour
un appel ma foi tant mieux une astuce
maintenant pour les écrans super amoled
de samsung lorsque vous voulez vraiment
économiser de la batterie
ce que je vous conseille c'est de mettre
votre fond d'écran en noir tout noir ce
qui fait que ça ne consommera pas et que
vous allez vraiment économiser en termes
de durée de vie batterie alors pourquoi
pas avoir un fond tout noir directement
dans votre téléphone que vous pouvez
changer lorsque voyez vous arriver
vraiment vers un niveau critique de
batterie ça nous permettra quant à elle
de garder quelques précieuses minutes
une astuce maintenant pour iphone si par
exemple vous voulez écouter de la
musique le soir pour vous endormir sur
des podcasts ce soit à la radio que ce
soit sur spotify ou un dans votre
application musique avec votre playlist
ou autres ce que vous faites vous allez
dans le minuteur et dans le minuteur
vous choisissez en mode sonnerie arrêter
la lecture tout en bas vous mettez bien
évidemment le temps vous souhaitez et
lorsque le temps sera passé une
demi-heure une heure ce que vous voulez
ça s'arrêtera sa coupera et vous pourrez
vous endormir avec vos écouteurs dans
les oreilles
voilà le seul inconvénient maintenant
c'est que ça n'arrivera pas vos
écouteurs mais en tout cas vous ne serez
pas déranger vous risquez pas de vous
réveiller une heure après avec de la
musique plein wallon il existe
l'équivalent sur android par contre sont
des applications que vous allez pouvoir
trouver directement sur le plein store
autre astuce sur android souvent votre
téléphone que commencé à ramer et
manquer de place simplement parce que
vous avez des applications qui vous
prennent énormément de place ce que je
vous conseille vous allez dans vos
paramètres vous
aller dans les paramètres des
applications vous regardez les
applications il ya la centaine qui vont
vous prendre un peu trop de place
notamment des applis comme facebook ou
autre est ce que vous faites c'est que
vous vider le cache vous allez voir ça
va vous allez j'ai tout de suite votre
stockage et ça pourra retourner un petit
peu mieux autre astuce très intéressant
sur android lorsque votre téléphone et
par du vous avez la possibilité de
configurer un message qui s'affichera
directement sur l'accueil de votre
téléphone bien évidemment la personne ne
pourra pas le déverrouiller belle pour
avoir soit un numéro de téléphone soit
ni mail pour pouvoir vous contacter si
bien évidemment elle est honnête et
qu'il ne décide pas de le garder pour
elle en tout cas si vous tombez sur
quelqu'un d'honnête et sachez qu'il
existe encore ça peut vraiment vous
sauver la vie
on va terminer avec une dernière astuce
pour iphone une astuce qui vous servira
pas forcément grand chose mais que
personne nous quasiment pas grand monde
ne connaît qui vous permettra avoir
accès à toutes les informations
concernant votre opérateur téléphonique
et votre géolocalisation il faut taper
le code étoiles 3 001 jays 1 2 3 4 5
diez étoiles puis vous appuyez sur le
bouton appel ça va vous ouvrir un menu
sur lequel vous trouverez toutes les
informations sur votre opérateur
téléphonique sur votre géolocalisation
alors bien évidemment je n'hésite pas à
dire n'importe quoi mais on découvre
comme ça un menu qu'on ne connaissait
pas qui normalement vous ai pas didier
mais ça permet d'en savoir un peu plus
et puis aller trifouiller devoir après
ça si vous êtes curieux paul un peu pour
les a tous aujourd'hui pour ios et
android pour aller plus loin pour
optimiser et améliorer votre smartphone
dites moi vous si vous en connaissez
certaines autres que je n'ai pas cité
vous pouvez les marques et en
commentaire je vous invite à me céder
jolie pousse à vous a donné parce qu'il
y aura beaucoup beaucoup et beaucoup de
contenu de tutos et d'astuces pour vous
aider dans votre vie numérique que ce
soit avec vos smartphones que ce soit
énormément de choses n'oubliez pas d'ici
quelques temps je suis en déplacement au
csa l'aide à las vegas excusez moi pour
vous raconter toutes les nouveautés à
venir sur votre vie numérique donc
abonnez vous restez connectés et quant à
moi je vous dis à très bientôt je vous
embrasse
et d'ici là portez vous bien chargé